le 19 octobre
les canadiennes et les canadiens vont
faire un choix sérieux entre une
expérience concrète qui a fait ses
preuves et une approche dangereuse
les canadiens méritent un prémunissent
qui a l'expérience et le leadership
nécessaire pour réparer les dommages
causés par stephen âmes
le clan de monsieur harper a échoué et
le plan de monsieur mulcair n'est qu'un
mirage
le bloc québécois est un parti
indépendant des seuls intérêts que de
défendre ce sont les veaux ceux des
québécoises et des québécois
alors un petit saut en arrière c'était
il ya 40 jours déclenchement de cette
longue campagne
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on en a fait
la moitié ne reste plus que l'équivalent
d'une campagne traditionnelle puis
sérieusement si vous leur a promise est
justement sur cette campagne de deux
mois pourrait souffler ses adversaires
pourrait-il perdre son pari
daniel et à ottawa tâche à toronto
michel ici à montréal bonsoir à vous
trois tâches avait commencé avec vous
parce que vraiment pour les
conservateurs ça c'est difficile ce qui
se passe en ce moment il ya ces crise
des réfugiés qui prend toute la place
dans la campagne
monsieur harper avait tenu la ligne dure
pas plus de réfugiés on accueillerait
pas plus d'être de réfugiés là il
entrouvre la porte et il dit bon
peut-être qu'on pourrait accélérer le
processus est ce qui est en train de
mettre un genou à terre par exactement à
genoux et c'est pas son style du tout je
pense est une réalisation qu'il faut que
le gouvernement agisse dans ce dossier
là et pas simplement dire que ce qu'on
fait c'est assez
il ya eu un gouvernement dans la
campagne conservatrice cette semaine et
on voit ça parce qu'à cause et aussi des
sondages qui démontrent que le parti se
retrouve un troisième place alors je
pense qu'il ya un sentiment qu'il faut
démontrer de l'axé ans sinon le coeur
dans cette affaire qui était l'élément
manquant je pense qui a tourné les
électeurs contre le parti daniel donc
c'est vrai tâche à la raison c'est pas
le genre de monsieur un peu le changer
d'idée mais là quand même
il ya eu de la pression il s'est senti
il a été forcé de change étant bien
attendons voir aussi qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire exactement le détail et les
changements et ce sont les détails il
faudra voir qu'est ce qui va changer
quelque quelques trucs pour sauver la
face ou si ce sera des changements en
profondeur est ce qu il y aura une toute
nouvelle approche à la question des
réfugiés d'achat le dis vous l'avez dit
aussi c'est pas dans l'adn de stephen
harper de changer d'idée ou d'effectuer
des grands virages mais il a une
campagne qui ne va nulle part qui a
beaucoup de difficultés il est fin seul
sur le terrain dans tous les laits dans
tous les pays il ya toujours deux
ministres très importants sur lesquels
on peut compter qu'ils peuvent devenir
les messagers du parti 15e chef des
programmes s'agit habituellement des
ministres des finances et du ministre
des affaires étrangères dans les deux
cas joe a levé a complètement disparu et
je vous mets au défi de me nommer le
ministre des affaires étrangères voulzy
s'appelle va mener comme sunyer cas du
journal et sont venus mais paris s'est
sauvé donc il ya un problème majeur
d'organisation je regarde si venard plus
depuis une semaine j'ai l'impression
qu'il est découragée qu'il est résigné
sauf que seven un peu c'est stephen
harper a il va sûrement tenter quelques
grands coups pour sauver la baraque
michel est ce qu'on est encore dans une
course à trois casses et l'ennemi reste
vous avez 10 38 jours c'est la durée
d'une campagne normale donc
théoriquement il peut se passer encore
bien des choses mais j'ai pas
l'impression que monsieur un peu
va être capable de remonter la pente au
coût de la dea d'études qui se répète
jour après jour ils semblent incapables
ou même le pauvre vouloir vraiment
essayé de répondre au besoin de
changement on a l'impression qu'il est
convaincu que ce qui fait c'est la bonne
chose est que il va il va vivre ou
mourir avec avec ses politiques
même l'histoire des réfugiés écoutez il
y a même pas l'air de savoir ce qu'il
veut faire c'est trop peu trop tard ça
donne l'impression simplement de faire
de la récupération de dernière minute
alors je pense qu'on est davantage dans
une course à deux maintenant et c'est là
que ça devient vraiment intéressant
parce que il ya quelques temps je vous
aurais dit en début de campagne en tout
cas je vous aurais dit que en bout de
ligne c'est un mannequin qui sortirait
gagnant d'une cause comme celle-là mais
maintenant j'en suis plus sûr du tout je
dois vous le dire depuis le début de la
campagne depuis le débat en particulier
lors du début de campagne
je suis passablement impressionné par la
performance de monsieur trudeau et dieu
sait que mes attentes étaient faibles et
là on est mans je ne serai pas vraiment
surpris que c'est lui qui en bout de
ligne ne peuvent pas former un
gouvernement majoritaire mais qui
finissent par se ramasser avec les plus
grand nombre de sièges qui pourraient se
retrouver premier ministre venant de
vous michel c'est quand même je suis le
premier étonné je suis très étonné de
vous dire sa 16ème sila michel ce que
j'ai dit c'est la course à deux entre
les deux partis de centre gauche les
libéraux et le pbd c'est complètement
différent que une course de anti harper
de choix ça pourrait être mieux qu'un
autre udo contre monsieur rock comme
étant les conservateurs tombe en
troisième place c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour le [ __ ] c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les libéraux parce que
tout le jeu
l'intérêt et des conservateurs s'étaient
dégradées et libéraux au milieu mais là
si ça devient une course entre monsieur
michael mais c'est trudeau c'est la
question de l'incarnation du changement
et monsieur trudeau sur plusieurs plans
incarne un peu plus le changement
générationnel et hétéros comme chez
mulcair qui est un style et une nage un
peu plus proche de sa vie de monsieur
harper alors c'est c'est plus difficile
ensuite pour et les conservateurs et le
npd de changer cette donne
daniel comment expliquer alors ce succès
de monsieur trudeau dans cette campagne
écoutez il est jeune beaucoup de jeunes
ceux qui s'intéressent à la politique
fédérale i alors propre pas des tonnes
les y en a sont très attirées vers lui
il est toujours bonne humeur il fallait
une campagne de rockstar deux vedettes
des gens aiment ça les gens trouvent
brutaux fin il dit pas trop de deux de
niaiser jusqu'à maintenant ce qui était
beaucoup de contenu du fond en se disant
bon on va faire trébucher à tous les
jours il avait la réputation de souvent
s'accrocher dans des dossiers qu'un pas
quand même pas tellement difficile il
n'a pas fait d'erreur il fait pas
d'erreur ici où il s'en va il ya joué
très très très gros en promettant ou de
faire des déficits de 10 milliards va
aller des gens se sont dit c'est une
erreur à cette semaine encore avec peter
mansbridge quand il dit les pme les
petites et moyennes entreprises souvent
c'est des profiteurs qui ne veulent que
sauver des impôts à mon avis c'est une
erreur sauf que personne ne lui en tiens
trop rigueur sauf ces veinards peu bref
à tout fonctionne pour lui il reste
quatre débats les deux débats en france
je pense qu'il est plus vulnérable et
c'est là où on va vraiment voir de
quelle est de quel bois ils se chauffent
le siège basé à l'hésitation
c'est à dire il va être
débat sur l'économie aussi ça va pas
être facile pour lui non plus et on sait
pas si on va avoir un deuxième débat
anglophones bilingues comme on dit sur
la politique étrangère parce que
maintenant et libéraux essaie d'en
sortir mais c'est passé ghislain mais il
reste que tout le monde disait depuis
des mois sinon des années que dans un
débarras les trois monsieur trudeau ce
fait écrabouiller et c'est vraiment pas
ce qui est arrivé la première fois et je
pense qu'il a pris beaucoup d'assurance
et que ça va être beaucoup plus
difficile de le coincer dans les
prochains débats mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire mais shell pour monsieur
mulcair alors si tout à coup c'est
justin trudeau qui incarne ce changement
c'est un gros problème pour monsieur
mulcair en particulier en ontario où là
il ya un jeu du c'est la fin il doit
incarner le changement mais à la fois ne
pas ressusciter le fantôme de ben aubry
et sa le dosage est particulièrement
difficile
hélas ce puisque je trouve c'est que
monsieur marqué il joue trop facile si
vous me passez l'expression il manifeste
une prudence tel qu on dirait que il
perd la fraîcheur qu'incarnait le npd
jusqu'à présent et tandis que monsieur
monsieur trudeau lui est vraiment
audacieux
daniel bien dix mois sa réplique sa
réponse amène ce bridge sur les pme j'ai
trouvé ça rafraîchissant ça m'a un peu
rappelé l' éco-prêt tout à refaire bones
de la vie de l'ouest et je trouve que
monsieur trudeau surprend et monsieur
matière je pense déçoit un peu
à tel point que monsieur trudeau est
capable de le comparer maintenant à
monsieur à monsieur a pris 1,10 à
écouter regarder même affaire un peu
marc un déficit à tout prix coupure ces
petits pas du changement ça mais c'est
ça que les deux parties se sont inversés
position traditionnellement l'un des
plus à gossau libéraux mais sur les
mesures comme le déficit sur les
commentaires sur les pme par exemple les
libéraux se positionne à gauche tu npd
et c'est vrai que ce que michel dit
monsieur mulcair doit être prudent parce
qu'il ne veut pas que les dés semblent
être une réincarnation de l'aisne [ __ ] de
bob rae qui était irresponsable sur le
plan fiscal
en ce faisant il devient un peu plus
conservateur dans son approche
économique de l'est et thomas mulcair le
même défi que brahim que me voler avec
sylvain à feu si l'on ne peut doit
relancer sa campagne dans l'ensemble du
pays
il doit absolument le faire et
rapidement sinon ils proposent remonter
la côte est et en angleterre doit
trouver une façon de percer en ontario
pour l'instant ça ne lève pas du tout et
le danger c'est que si on le voit aller
en ontario ont voté ailleurs bon à la
solution de rechange et pas moyen
c'est justin trudeau et c'est vrai aussi
au québec on sera peut-être moins tentés
de voter pour mulcair si on se rend
compte que c'est trudeau il ya plusieurs
indépendantiste que les choix michel
s'est jouée tron qui sont prêts à voter
pour le npd est ce qu'ils sont prêts à
suivre
trudeau j'en suis moins certain pas
convaincu que non si on voit que trudeau
apprend la vence il ya des choses dans
le reste du pays a des chances de former
un gouvernement il y aura peut-être un
petit effet benoît genk au monde il a
rallié le camp du gagnant mais de façon
générale je pense pas qu'il ya eu 6 à
déstabiliser réellement le npd pour deux
raisons d'abord monsieur mathieu a
réussi contre toute attente parce que
saguenay était détesté il ya quelques
années mais à se faire aimer au québec
et accords qui lient québécois
n'auraient pas adopté mais surtout
surtout le vote bloquiste qui est passé
au npd en 2011 ne passera pas chez les
libéraux trudeau c'est gentil et fin qui
peut se paraître pendant la campagne ça
reste un trudeau qui est chef de ce
parti libéral et tout ça rappelle de
très mauvais souvenirs à des souris
rennais s'est même à des nationalistes -
plus moody's
j'aimerais juste qu'on revienne à la
campagne de stephen ont un peu quand
même
tasha aidez nous à comprendre ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur du camp conservateur
est ce que on sent une certaine panique
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de mouvements
quand même dans l'entourage de monsieur
un peu on essaie de rectifier le tir on
a même fait venir elle stratège
australien apparemment célèbre oui
quelqu'un qui est fait élire ouaki et
contribuer à la campagne
l' élection de boris johnson le maire de
londres qui est connu aussi qui a visé
selon les conservateurs à vis de
campagne depuis bhoutan s'est pas
complètement nouveau mais maintenant il
est là on pense que tu es aussi que
jamie benn la directrice de campagne et
a été rapatriée à ottawa est qu à côté
du premier ministre et il ya des
grondements dans le parti à son égard
les gens disent qu'elle contrôle est
trop le message avait trop peu de gens
qui a visé le premier ministre et que
toute la question des deux candidats qui
est bon qu'ils ont fait des mauvaises
choses
uriner dans une tasse et l'autre d'aider
à tous et higuain tombale 10h la figue
été ensuite l'autre qui avait dit des
sottises sur youtube que ces gens là
c'est la gestion de tout ça il était en
colère contre elle et colère contre
contre l'équipe
alors il ya des bouleversements au sein
de la campagne et c'est toujours une psy
un signe que les choses ne vont pas bien
et je signe de désespoir tout simplement
si vous trouvez pas des conservateurs
assez fort et dans le parti et parmi les
ministres et chez les conservateurs de
l'ontario et chez les conservateurs de
l'alberta pour relever ce parti là vous
devez aller en australie
c'est l'agression c'est vraiment
responsable de son malheur si les seuls
aujourd'hui si a pas deux minutes sur le
terrain parce que les mines s il les a
ni plus ni moins écarté pendant tout son
règne
à part peut-être monsieur flare et
équipements
et pendant que monsieur mais qu'il met
au tram à monsieur a fait le vide dans
lequel il se retrouve aujourd'hui c'est
vrai on a beaucoup parlé cette semaine
un téléjournal de cette concentration
des pouvoirs au bureau du premier
ministre
mais voilà c'est déjà le tout le temps
qu'on a merci beaucoup à vous trois on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine et
dimanche à 11 heures aux polices du
pouvoir et manuela traverse entretien
avec le chef du bloc québécois gilles
duceppe